[Musique]
s'inscrit net un mur antibruit
photovoltaïques dont qui s'adresse aux
abords de d'autoroutes et de voies
ferroviaires est plutôt dans des zones
urbaines mais son but donc ces deux en
même temps améliorer lutter contre les
nuisances sonores et générer une
électricité photovoltaïque c'est un
c'est un mur acoustique donc
verticalement on a des panneaux
acoustiques qui vont atténuer le bruit
est au sommet de ces panneaux nous avons
en appel une casquette photovoltaïque
c'est à dire que j'ai panneaux
photovoltaïques incliné comme ça comme
un forme de toile du mur
[Musique]
là haut niveau de l'expérimentation on a
bien tester la fonctionnalité acoustique
et production d'énergie mais l'enjeu
pourrait être aussi de rajouter des
services associés à ce mur antibruit
donc des services liés à la route du
suivi de la détection de d'accidents de
monitoring environnementales ou destin
risquer à des recharge des véhicules
électriques pour pour les abords des
autoroutes
aujourd'hui alors qu'on est encore en
phase de développement sur des revenir
des démonstrateurs une approche des 20%
de surcoûts donc avec l'ambition de les
diminuer grâce à des projets de grande
échelle donc là aujourd'hui on
travaillait aux mureaux c'est une
longueur de 5 mètres de mur et
autour on travaille sur 100 m de murs
mais ça reste encore petit